the democratic republic of congo is home
to the un's largest peacekeeping mission
yet a violent insurgency in the country
shows no signs of abating for nearly
three decades eastern congo has been
marred
with insecurity and frequent outbreaks
of violence caused by armed groups
last year more than 2 000 civilians were
killed in attacks
by these rebels now there are said to be
over 100 armed groups in the region and
experts say the deadliest among them
is the islamist group adf short for
allied democratic forces now the un's
monusco
mission which has been on the ground
since 2010 has deployed over 17
000 peacekeeping troops in the region
but as our dw team found the mission
has not brought peace or security to
people there
these are soldiers from south africa and
their task is to secure this region
which is considered a red zone because
of repeated attacks by the islamist
group adf
so we're going to follow them for one
day
it feels a bit odd to move in an armored
vehicle like this
while people outside seem to live a
normal everyday life
but the impression is deceptive this
area is dangerous
attacks happen almost on a daily basis
the islamist militia
adf has carried out repeated massacres
killing more than 500 people in the
second half of 2020.
we are on our way to the village of
maimoya very close to that village six
kilometers away there was an adf attack
two months ago
so this area where we're heading to is
considered as being secured but they can
always have an attack
with the un troops we visit a clinic in
maimoya
that has been targeted by adf in the
past
is the director here he's witnessed
gruesome attacks
the militia slaughters people and when
you see the animosity they have to kill
these people
how they cut off the heads you find
their brains scattered all over
they hack off feet that leaves you with
fear and traumatizes your heart
in one incident the islamists tried to
kidnap four
of his nurses
they found them in the waiting room and
took them hostage once people realized
it was adf they were very afraid but
then the militias said they won't kill
them they said
it is not a day to kill
because of the constant threat the
clinic is only open for a few hours in
the morning
women and children struggle to get the
medical care they need
they struggle with food they cannot go
and plow they cannot go and farm
they have to stay at home they cannot
move the children cannot go to school
a woman cannot come to the clinic as
well the villagers have experienced a
lot
but many are reluctant to speak to us
according to the intelligence officer
here at monusco
some villages are related to adf members
and feed them with information about
activities of the un troops and the
congolese army
the local population is in a tight
corner some of their sons and daughters
have joined
adf and often provide them with food but
in return the villagers have to
cooperate
and provide the militia group with
information or risk getting killed
sometimes we are happy and sometimes we
are afraid
because they can come today or tomorrow
they have now become our everyday people
just when we were about to leave a man
wants to speak to us out of fear he
doesn't want to be named
the government should help or the
international community should help our
government to deal with this phenomenon
that has made a lot of people suffer adf
should be finished
finished finished
his frustration is palpable and sums up
what many people here told us off-camera
their feeling is they are being brutally
massacred while the outside world
needs to act urgently
and we spoke to david zuma of the un
group of experts on the democratic
republic
of congo and also a senior researcher at
the institute of security studies in
pretoria we asked him if
the u.n peacekeeping mission in congo
had failed
look monisco is a response to a complex
problem
they have to deal with big territory and
they have to face 150
armed groups scattered around the
country
some of them are sponsored by
politicians who use them
to be to secure their position in
kinshasa the relation between monusco
and the government
previous administration under kabila has
also not been good
to facilitate the activities of the
institutions and you know
municipal work in the government near
the country where government is capable
to accompany what they have to do in
terms of peacekeeping this has been
lacking in the dlc for the past 10 years
but you really need to know exactly what
adf is you know there have been many
components
within what is called the allied
democracy force in in benin
a certain time they appear as ugandan
rebel group
who are trying to return to uganda to
challenge your muslim regime
at another time particularly since 2016
they have turned their guns against the
congolese
citizens now we are also hearing that
there might be some connection between
them and islamic state
in the region so you have all those in
one item and then you need to make a
difference
between the various components of that
institution to be able to engage in in
dialogue
the drc and international partners are
trying to win
other rebels you know in north korea in
south carolina province
through negotiation but they don't have
the logistical support they don't have a
financial support and there is no clear
plan
in terms of a ddr in place to absorb
those who might want to to leave the arm
group
to join the civilian civilian that they
have been experiences before
but those experiences have failed and
have not really produced a kind of
response responses that one could have
expected
for states to move to instability to
submitted peace i think the new
political dispensation and that way i
mean
in kinshasa is to see how this provides
an opportunity
for the drc government and various
actors to initiate
key reforms that will help the country
to move forward
the one front is simply to review the
electoral process to allow citizens to
express their will
on who they want to to lead the country
legitimacy the second one is also to
undertake
institutional reforms that would have a
dlc to respond to the basic need of
the congolese citizen and what is
happening now in terms of a sacred union
or union with political forces could
provide a momentum for this
to help the effort of international
community to take their seat forward
but it's not going to be something that
is going to happen overnight they're
going to take a bit of time
but between now and 2023 i think if the
jersey government
work with the momentum or current
momentum that can send a strong message
that the drc is capable of overcoming
some of the key challenges that we just
highlight